hello guys my name is a cello and
welcome to episode 2 of season 2 of game
programming so last time we basically
just took an introductory kind of
planning session as to what we would do
in this season and specifically what we
would do multiplayer wise so we're up to
the point of bringing rain our game to
be a multiplayer game and so we have a
lot of things that we need to set up for
that and obviously right all over the
networking code and we kind of just went
over the plan so if you guys haven't
seen the previous episode you're gonna
want to watch that first it'll be a
annotation on my face or something or I
just realized my face doesn't take up
the whole screen they'll be in an
annotation on the screen somewhere to go
back and watch the previous episode so
do that if you haven't or if you just
want to refresh or as well but basically
what we're going to do now is put that
plan into action by beginning to write
all that code so I've well last time I
wrote this little to do here that says
connect to server here and I kind of
went over the order and and the order of
this is gonna be pretty important as
well because what will happen is I mean
I remember right now like this was like
the last season
but we did we added this whole net
player thing and that would kind of be
like if we launched this thing right now
I think the net player was GA like this
little thing we basically just
experimented with having an entity here
which is a mob yeah whatever Google
Drive we had this entity here which is a
mob and um I mean I'm not even sure what
we'd really did with this we have we
were setting acts to a certain position
but the point is we managed to make a
mob that was kind of in this net a
section of our code base which is going
to be important as well because we're
going to receive information from the
server as to which net play is to add
and all that stuff so it's gonna be
pretty exciting once we get all that up
and running so to begin doing that the
first thing I decided I want to do is
actually set up the server so we're
gonna make a new project for this so
right over here now navigator or in your
package Explorer however you roll if you
just right-click and hit new you can
select Java project and I'm going to
type in rain server
okay and it's going to be our server
this is going to be a completely
standalone application as I covered last
time last week in the planning session
we are going to have a standalone
service that we have like a
client-server kind of setup right where
we have a single server and then
multiple clients connect to that server
and the only way the clients communicate
to each other is through that server
right there's not gonna be any kind of
peer-to-peer stuff it's just gonna be
client to server and so of course we
need a server for that to work so we're
gonna look at our current name-space so
we have com.com the Cherno rain and then
we have sure okay so I guess what I'll
set up here or what package I'm gonna
put all this in is gonna be com daughter
Cherno dot rain server I could do rain
dot server and I guess that way it would
kind of be anything but that's just too
many like this is clearly gonna be the
server so I'm happy to just leave it
like that so we don't have too many
folders here ok cool and so what we'll
do is we'll just call this I guess main
I'm actually going to call it rain
server the reason is that it'll just
make it a little bit easier to because
we've already got main for here I might
be actually what game here yeah but
still I'll call it rain server so this
is gonna be the main class I'm going to
just make sure I take this here so that
it automatically generates my main
method and that's it we've created a
brand new java application that is
specifically going to be our server now
this has nothing to do with this that's
one thing I want to quickly mention as
well we will be referencing one project
with this but it won't be rain it'll be
the rain cloud sterilization project
right because we want to be able to use
that sterilization stuff that we wrote
inside this rain server project but we
are not going to link rain server and
rain together at all they don't go
together at all they completely
standalone things as far as they know
like they don't they don't share any
code at all okay they're completely
different things the only thing that the
rain server is responsible for doing is
basically receiving data transforming it
somehow and then sending it back right
that's what happens it's as simple as
that it receives down river network it
does something to it or it might send my
create new data based on that data it
receives right and then it sends it back
into the network and that's it
so the way that I like to develop this
thing is honestly is just really kind of
trying to oversimplify things III don't
want to say oversimplify because what
we're doing here isn't really simple
right but it also is in a sense right
when you boil down any kind of any kind
of software engineering problem right
it does actually become quite simple you
just have to really think about it and
break it down into small enough chunks
and really the problem that you're
solving should never be excessively
difficult now I'm talking about most
things that you guys will probably end
up doing right I mean obviously there
are problems out there that are really
difficult to solve but this isn't this
isn't one of them okay in terms of a
high-level approach it's a really simple
problem that we're trying to solve we're
simply trying to accept data read it
process it generate new data send it
back to that thing that sent us the
initial data okay that's all we're doing
so that's my personal approach to these
kind of problems I like to I like the
things to think through them right and
just make sure that I'm not overthinking
it right
do not over complicate things that's the
worst thing you can do in software
engineering in my opinion is to over
complicate things because that's when
you start deferring writing the actual
code like I am right now
no but seriously that's when you start
kind of delaying and deferring the
writing of code and you start having you
know more and more time to think about
the design and you stop procrastinating
essentially okay so over complication is
terrible over simplification in factors
better I would argue but the point is
that's all we're trying to do here so
that's how we're gonna start off we're
not gonna start off writing this
incredible net code here we're just
gonna get these true projects
communicating rain and rain server over
the network okay if we can do that if I
can set up a laptop over here right next
to me and I can connect to this and and
I can see the information that's being
transmitted between those two that's
that's a success so that's going to be
our first goal right just the
transmission and I guess the sending and
the receiving of data from two separate
hosts
okay virus server so basically just
client to server server
that's all I want sorry microphone keep
hitting this thing um anyway that's
that's the idea that's how step one okay
so to do that we're just gonna start off
with making a simple clasp here I'm
actually not even sure what to call this
I might call this server or something
I'm actually really not sure what to
call this because I was going to call it
rain server but and I decided to call
the main class rain server so I guess
I'll just call this server and it's
gonna be count kind of it like our main
server class it's going to contain all
of our methods that we're going to need
for actual server code okay
so the first thing what and also one
thing I should note is that this class
instance right an instance of server
literally represents an instance of you
know the rain server so if you make
another for instance of this class it's
gonna be another server okay I mean the
name should imply that as well that's
that's another thing I want to mention
right with object-oriented programming
and stuff you really want to make sure
that objects actually represent objects
right you're not just making classes for
absolutely everything because you don't
you've been taught to do that that's
another thing that I'd really don't like
about object-oriented programming is
when it becomes more about classes than
actual code and functionality right I
mean as much as you want your code to be
beautiful you also don't want to be just
creating classes for absolutely
everything because you have no idea how
to solve the problem without that right
anyway one thing I want to mention for
this series right away actually because
this is still episode 2 of season 2 is
I'm probably going to introduce some
more kind of software engineering
approaches and I'm gonna talk a little
bit more about programming guidelines
and like stuff like that right so if you
guys are cool with that
just let me know what you think of that
or if you would prefer like because I
don't want to just aimlessly write code
for you guys I mean if you want to if
you want to like ok you could do two
things if you just want to jump to all
the code straight away you can just
support me on patreon right five dollars
a month gets you access to the github
repository which has all of what I'm
going to write in like the next five
episodes already written right but B you
could just look at the thousands of
open-source projects that have a
client-server thing and written in Java
for example right so I mean I'm not like
I'm not trying to bring something
totally new to the table I'm just trying
to go over my thought process when I
approach problems like this and how I'm
going to solve it and why ice why I
write the code that I do okay so that's
kind of the way that I'm gonna lay out
this series so let me know what you
think of that but um that's kind of my
opinion I think that that's probably the
way I'm gonna do it because it's just it
makes sense to me okay so when we start
up a server again we are starting a new
server so the one thing that we really
do need to provide is a port okay we
don't need an IP address or anything
like that
obviously now server is the IP address
the IP address of the server is going to
be localhost right and for anyone else
connecting to the server it's going to
be either the server the server is local
or external IP address right so it's all
fine we don't need to do anything with
that but we do need a port okay because
the port is just going to define which
port our application is going to connect
to the network through okay and our
application being the server in this
case so we'll have a private int port I
want to quickly cover this as well and
one thing right I want to say as well is
that this series is gonna be a lot of me
talking about stuff by the way so just
get used to that or leave I mean either
way but I was gonna say that the
original game programming series was a
lot of this as well like I was
introducing stuff like hey what does
private do right obviously I'm not gonna
do that because the original game
programming series was all like the
season one rather was more about
teaching you guys like Java as well like
along the way if a hey game now I kind
of assume that you know what Java like
how Java works at least syntactically
okay and what all the keywords do okay
but I'm not going to I am going to kind
of comment on things that that are
general kind of coding practices and and
also my style okay because a lot of
these things like in terms of coding
practices sure there are a lot of like
there are a lot of general like do this
don't do that there's a lot of that kind
of stuff right and there are actual
concrete cases in which like there is
under nose
you should do this right there do exist
like things like that essentially rules
that you really shouldn't follow but
then also there are a lot of things that
are just opinions okay and I'm just
gonna comment on my opinions so if you
don't agree with my style or like the
way I write code or the way I do that
that's totally fine like this is a you
know I'd to think that this world is
kind of freeing and certainly something
as as insignificant as programming you
are totally free to write code the way
you want right I mean it's you know it's
your life you can do what you want I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna like force you
to do this as if it's like some huge
deal it's not right
but I'm just going to comment on the way
I do things so that if you guys like
that or if you guys don't get why I do
things then you can see right and maybe
I'll teach you something new that you
don't know that's the goal so a lot of
people ask me why I make things public
all the time
now in this case I may have made the
port private but sometimes I will make
public variables and again I get a lot
of questions where people say why why
I've been taught like they will they
will tell me that they've been taught to
make the variable private and then just
make a getter and a setter so you have
something called get port and you have
something called set port and then you
do that this gets taught a lot
unfortunately because I think it's
really stupid I honestly think that this
is one of the worst things ever in fact
this is like one of those things that
Java is actually kind of known for for
some reason I mean with like a c-sharp
which is kind of the other popular
managed programming language out there
you kind of have properties this was a
little bit different because that's kind
of implied like you know in c-sharp for
example you'd make a plot you'd make a
public in called port and then you'd
have like get said or something like
that and that's kind of done and that's
kind of your getter and setter in one
right and you have that automatically in
Java you don't have that so you end up
having to create the methods yourself
okay or a c-sharp will kind of hide it
behind syntactical sugar i guess just to
just to make a syntax with nicer fire
properties and then generate these
methods in
actual kind of generated code but the
idea is Java doesn't provide that so you
end up and we said like this this is
stupid I don't understand why people do
this I really do not right
there is no point in doing this
whatsoever right get rid of these two
methods make the variable public you
will achieve exactly the same thing and
it'll look nicer and you won't have
extra methods that the that your CPU
will then need to call right I mean
hopefully this stuff like this gets
inlined but that's besides the point
right I'm not gonna talk about
optimization here I'm just talking about
and performance I'm just gonna talk
about just how much that messes up the
codebase right I mean in a situation
like this it's not the worst thing in
the world like it is pretty bad and I
would never do it myself but if you've
got like a vector class or something
like a mathematical vector class and
you've got private int X Y Z from a
private float X Y Z and then get set for
each one of those then just please stop
doing that
honestly I don't know it's like please
stop doing that it's just you don't do
that
ok I'm actually just gonna say that
don't do that it's really stupid and I
don't like it
ok that being said if you'd like it and
if that's your style
yeh but just for the rest of you who are
unsure pick my way because it's the
correct way in this case ok I'm not
always right but I am in this case that
being said if I just wanted to make that
brings us back to the first kind of
point and I know this is gonna be the
longest video about writing one line of
code ever but this is what this series
is about right it's about learning how
to write code not necessarily just how
to make a game it's actually how to make
a game right and it's not how to make
this game it's just how to make games
and it's how to program and that's kind
of what this is about so sorry if I if I
seemed kind of pissed off today I'm just
I'm not really but I'm just kind of I
really want to have a bit of a clear
definition of what we're doing here ok
so that's the way that that works but
that being said why don't I make it
private because I'm not gonna have a set
on ok I'm just gonna have a getter so by
doing that I've effectively made the
variable read-only from outside this
class right so any class outside of the
server class for example drain server
where we're going to you know
instantiate our server so server server
people the new server will say port 8
one line - you guys know from the
network share programming series that is
my favourite portable time for some
reason when we do something like this
I'm not going to be able to do anything
you can see I'm not exposed to port so I
can't change the port and if I do that
of course that's not going to work
because well it copies the variable
right it just returns a copy of what
five is it doesn't give me a reference
to that port integer so I definitely
can't assign stuff like that to it like
I could in C++ if we were returning a
reference that's a reference for example
okay so in Java that's always gonna
return a copy of the integer so there's
no way I can do that right so there's no
way for me to actually set port and
that's the way I want it to be right
when you when you or at least for now
when you do something like this when you
create a server you're not promotes
change ports because what you would have
to do anyway is shuttle to shut the
server down and create a new server okay
so you could have a set port that does
that for you
but again we're just gonna say doesn't
risk a change Port Credit server if you
really want to change port
maybe close down the server and then
just make a new server which is on that
new port that you want to write 8 193 ok
so just a few things to think about the
other thing is I will note one other use
for having a private int and then both a
getter and setter and that is if you're
going to do more than just set the
variable if you have exactly this code
then yes that is bad don't do this right
but if you're doing some other stuff
like port times to it that's totally ok
now obviously this is a nonsensical case
because you wouldn't be doing this ever
like to make sense to just double the
port right but Wow
gotta have one of those every episode by
the way otherwise it's not a game
programming episode anyway if you're
doing something like that maybe you're
logging extra stuff like port was
changed maybe you're actually restarting
the server like I said you might want to
restart the server if this happens so
you'll actually you know restart server
with new port or something like this
then yeah you can have a getter and
setter that makes sense and again if I
see a getter and setter like that for
for variable I know that it's gonna do
some extra stuff
you just have that then make the
variable public please save us all some
time okay so we have a port we're going
to have a void called
a public void not even sure this should
really necessarily be public but we will
definitely have I'm actually probably
gonna make these things private so we'll
have a private void listen right we're
going to have a private void probably
process okay and then a private void or
a public void called send okay and the
general consensus here is we're going to
send some data processed as well is
probably going to process a packet okay
the packets that we're going to use is
UDP packets so that will be in Java it's
called a data ground packet okay
listen is generally going to be on a
separate thread which specifically
listens for things so basically we're
going to have a listen thread which when
we start the server which we will do in
a separate thing so that's another thing
that I generally with with things like
servers right I don't like to just
implicitly
have it so that when you create a new
server like this it automatically starts
it right I like to kind of separate my
creation and like setting up all the
data which is what this this is doing
right essentially we'll do some kind of
initialization stuff and then when I'm
ready true that's when I actually want
to start the server okay so we do I'll
kind of we begin listening on that
specific port you know in the start
method that way you can you're not tied
to having to create your server when you
want to start it you can do other stuff
here right and then eventually core
server they'll start when you're ready
okay that's very important to do in my
opinion so let's just say that but
that's very important to do right I said
I like doing that because it lets me do
other stuff and you again you might have
you know sets other properties you might
have other stuff that you want to set
you don't pass through the constructor
that you can now do because the server
hasn't started yet okay whereas you
would be basically tied to providing
everything through the constructor as
parameters if you if you didn't do that
okay
so again just a nice little thing that I
like doing so the listen thread is going
to be a new thread now we're going to
use the listen method as what the thread
is going to run right so this listen
method is going to be on this new thread
and so the way that I'm going to do that
in the past you would have had to in
Java like seven and below I think you
would have had to create a new runnable
anonymous inner type either that operate
a completely new class yourself but and
like usually you would do this right you
created an anonymous inner class class
with the run method which would call
listen and then you essentially get that
right and then of course you'd have to
start a thread now in Java eight so if
wasn't thread dot star and there you go
we've we've called this function now on
this listen thread on this new thread
now in Java eight however we're
introduced to lambdas which other
languages have had forever so a lambda
is basically just a way to take this
anonymous inner class and compress it
down into basically one line right and
basically what a lambda is usually is
kind of like it's essentially a function
that you're passing in okay you're
saying here's an anonymous function
rather than anonymous class which is
what this is right and then that
function can do something specific so
it's just a way to pass around functions
as actual kind of function pointers
essentially is what a lambda is it's
just a function so the way that that
would look like syntactically it's a
little bit weird and every language does
it differently Java does it with a weird
little arrow as I'll show you in a
minute
but basically we have first of all the
parameters that we take in to this new
function so if listen had any parameters
we would put them there or rather not
really because this is this isn't really
a lambda that we're creating for listen
it's actually a lambda that we're
creating for the run method this is
inside runnable so we're in that case
that method doesn't have parameters so
we don't need to worry about that but if
the run method did have parameters we
would be putting them in there we have
this weird arrow and then we can write
as much code as we want inside two curly
brackets right so and and then basically
this turns into the body of that run
method that we had okay so it becomes
really simple and I'll show you the
difference in a minute here but
basically we can now call the list
function now I think we can also do that
without these brackets if it's just one
line or maybe not actually can we yeah
there we go
right okay so we can if it's just one
line of code with like no semicolons or
whatever we don't have to use the curly
brackets to enclose it we can just do
something like that okay and that is
functionally equivalent to what happened
to what we did before it does exactly
the same thing it still creates that in
a class right it still does that in fact
I'm not sure if we can see here but you
may be able to see that inside the
compiled stuff not sure how that exactly
works there maybe not
can i browse to that specific thing yeah
okay it doesn't matter you'll have to
trust me that still doesn't say anything
it's just that it looks different so
again what it looked like before was
you're on a bull blah blah and then we
had the listen being called here so what
we've done basically is we've taken out
this new runnable part because we don't
need that at all we know it's a runnable
right we've taken out public void and
Ronn and we're left with the parameters
of run and then whatever we want us to
do okay there you go that's how that
works very simple and it will basically
call this on our on our other thread
okay
now the way that this is gonna work this
listening thing is we're basically gonna
have a boolean called listening we'll
probably end up making this volatile or
something like that and I'll cover like
concurrency specific Java keywords in a
completely separate episode but
ultimately we can use keywords such as
volatile to just make sure that the
compiler doesn't optimize out certain
things that would
our code because when we start changing
variables changing specific memory
addresses essentially from two different
threads we can get we can run into
problems okay because for example if
those two variables are both in the CPU
cache add in different locations and we
write to one of them then that cached
variable is not the same as the other
cached variable right and again the
reason that happens sometimes is if
we're running concurrently we might be
on separate CPU cores and separate CPU
cores have their own like l1 cache
essentially so you can run into a
variety of problems when you go into
like concurrency and stuff like that and
you might have to use fancy key words
like volatile but we'll cover that as we
need to and I'll try and actually
provide specific examples where we well
like not using volatile we'll
specifically not work okay
so that you guys can kind of see how
that actually works because a lot of
people just ride it for no reason
because they think that I'll okay I'm
running I'm gonna be losing listening on
this one thread so I better make a
volatile okay that's for example and
encourage use but anyway now we've got
that essentially this is going to be a
while kind of listening loop and we're
gonna do a bunch of stuff in here okay
so the reason we have a thread first of
all I know that's gonna be a question
why do we make a separate thread for
this why not just run listen from in
here without having to start a thread
right why don't we do this why didn't we
just you know not have that and just
call this okay the reason is that as you
can see there will be a while as
essentially a while true loop right when
we start the server we're going to set
listening it's true okay and we're gonna
basically sell a thread it doesn't
matter what order we do this in by the
way if we did that as well that will
work but if we did something like this I
actually why not which probably we
definitely should set that to true
otherwise we might skip past this entire
loop and an terminated thread but anyway
um the idea is that this is essentially
a while true loop okay a while true loop
will block the rest like it will a while
true loop blocks our current thread
right it's gonna be here until the while
true loop is broken out of or for
alternative okay so we obviously want to
keep doing other things
not just listening right we still want
to be able to process packets which will
actually happen from here but more
specifically we still want to be able to
like send data and do all that stuff
whilst also listening ok so to be able
to do things at the same time via having
kind of things that block us like a
while listening loop or a while true
loop we need to use multiple threads
another reason is that when we actually
do receive packets the way the packets
are received is essentially by kind of a
polling system what I mean by that is
that we'll call something like you know
we'll have like a socket and we'll call
something like a receive and what that
will do what that function will actually
do is block until it receives something
ok and we'll cover like terms like
blocking and stuff if you don't
understand that we'll definitely get
into that when we get some code to
actually run but this will block right
which means that if we have that on the
main thread again until a packet is
received we don't do anything right
where's that's not what 1 - even if
we're not receiving anything we still
want to be able to send stuff and do
other processing kind of tasks right so
we totally needed we totally need to
have a separate thread first stuff like
that and we'll talk about thread design
when we get to more advanced and more
specific examples right for example
having a thread per client might be a
bit excessive if we might have pools of
clients which I handle them up by
multiple threads and again there are
just so many things that we could do but
that is the basics of that so we have a
server which we can start we can listen
we can process so when we do receive
packets in this listening thing we'll
call the process function with them so
this will kind of run inside here I've
just split it up into a separate
function to make it a bit more organized
a bit neater and then of course we have
this hand method which we can call from
outside this as well whenever we want to
send data now right now this has no
address so we have no idea what we're
actually going to send it to so we will
probably have to specify some kind of
address but ultimately that's kind of
how that cookie crumbles so if you guys
enjoyed this episode please hit the like
button if you want to receive the code
from this episode and all that stuff
then you can just hop onto
around home for such the churner they'll
be a link in the description below if
you pledged at least $5 per month you
get access to all of that through a
private github repository as well as
like I came in by commit basis so you
get everything but that that's something
you can do if you want to support me and
you want to make sure these episodes
keep coming out on time then highly
recommend you do that if not then just
hit a like button on the video that
supports me as well of course it shows
me that you guys were interested and
I'll see you guys next week with episode
3 goodbye war